so we've had some time with the little
baby
30-70 now and michael hyam
you know talk to me about how this
powerful wee man performs
is that correct i wouldn't call it uh
call it
small or cute or compact it's still a
full-sized put it next to its brothers
yeah put it next to its brothers and
it's it
yeah it's uh it's a bit smaller but it
still packs a huge punch uh i mean uh
just to kind of give a broad overview
the rtx 3070 performs
on par or just barely behind the rtx
2080 ti
based on my results and that is
that's really impressive for a 500 card
um of course jury's still out on whether
or not you can actually find one
and find one for msrp but the fact of
the matter is that you can get
top and high end enthusiast level
performance
for what is relatively an affordable
price tag for a video card so that's
really exciting to see that nvidia
came out the gate and said that the 3070
was going to perform
on par or a little bit better than a
2080 ti say no more
uh that was already an exciting prospect
uh but to finally
put it to put it through its paces and
see how close
uh it actually comes to those bold
claims that nvidia was putting out
it's uh this is this is definitely the
card you want to upgrade to
yeah like i said jumping from 2080i
to 30 70 and like 2080 ti is still
that expensive and now assuming you can
get one like you said
370 is quite the bottom quote entry
level
but let's talk about some of the games
you were playing with like i know you've
you were
really like putting it through its paces
they're ready any standout
performances like you've when you've got
your full review and your full breakdown
on site right now but what are some of
like the standout wow moments from some
of the games you're testing
uh i think that i will i'll talk about
control first
because that is a case in which the
nvidia tech really gets the flex
there's dlss and there's a full ray
tracing suite available on control
control can be a very demanding game so
yeah at 4k when you turn all those
settings on and use dlss
uh it pretty much the the the
performance difference between the 2080
ti
and the 3070 they perform basically the
same
uh same thing that we see at 1440p
so regardless of the resolution you're
gonna get that same level of performance
but the thing is
is that with ray tracing i think that
even uh with these powerful cards i
think that
4k with a full suite of ray tracing is
still hitting
uh you're not gonna get 60 fps out of it
uh so
this card like don't expect to max
everything out with ray tracing at 4k
but what we see at 1440p
is performance that that's you can get
60 fps and you can
manage those frame rates at a very very
playable
um a very very playable experience
um but like if you want to do you can do
4k with this card like fairly easily you
just gotta turn some things down
metro exodus is one where it's a lot
more demanding but again this is another
case in which we cranked
everything to its max and the fact that
it can put out
this level of performance is pretty
exciting because not everyone's going to
play at 4k and not everyone's going to
like crank every single setting to its
maximum
so these are scenarios in which we're
like really pushing these cards
so if it lags behind the 2080 ti 3070 is
probably only like
four or five percent behind which isn't
that much like you're not going to
those aren't really noticeable
differences when you're actually playing
games
um so that's really cool to see these
high end games with the full ray tracing
suite um performing at this level
or someone who's you know after a new gp
but doesn't want to break the bank
like looking at your stats on a 30-70
1440p
average fps 52.9 with everything cranked
on metro exodus like that's that's
really impressive
i expected there to be more compromise
when it came to
getting in videos it's called a lower
tier card when it comes to performance
frames per second but it doesn't sound
like there's nearly as many
compromises as i thought like everything
all the numbers
seem to suggest that you're not giving
that up that much
when it comes to performance yeah uh
yeah and since you mentioned that i
think uh to put into perspective when it
comes to compared to the 3080
um of course it's a case-by-case basis
in how how much it lag is behind
and when i say lags behind i don't mean
that in like a detrimental sense because
this is a 200 this is a card that's 200
cheaper
than the 30 80. so generally i saw about
anywhere from 20 to 30 percent uh
performance
um decreases when going from the 30 80
to 30 70
and that's that's a reasonable gap for
the 200
uh the 200 gap in terms of pricing
so i think that the the the pricing and
the performance that you get out of it
are lining up really well
um and i say this in my review is that
not everyone wants the super high-end
stuff
uh if some people may have 4k displays
and they just want
they want manageable performance with
that 37 is going to give you that
or if you're at 1440p and you have a
high refresh rate monitor
and you have a good enough cpu the 3080
obviously is going to let you hit those
higher frame rates
but you can still get those super high
frame rates with the 30 70.
so it just depends on what your
expectations are
and 3070 really really does provide that
and there there are some cases where
especially at 1440p when things start to
be more cpu bound that's another thing
to consider is like like i mentioned
just
a few moments ago depends on what cpu
you have
there are some cases in which the 3080
only provides like a 10 to 12 percent
boost over the 30 70
because some games are just naturally
cpu bound and when you're at 14 if
you're at 1440p
um you really need to think about
whether or not you you're actually going
to get the most
out of a 3080 and whether or not you can
just like pocket a few bucks and go with
the 3070
right there so that that's another kind
of factor that you need to consider
4k 3080 is your card 370 can do that but
you know if you want to crank few things
down if you don't mind that to maintain
60
even higher fps man 3070 is
is is very impressive uh again like
we've been saying it this whole time but
it's really cool to see
a card that's a little bit more
affordable
do something like this uh so yeah it
just
you know it just really depends on what
your scenarios and what your
expectations are
um but across the board i think that um
3070 is definitely a card you want to be
looking at
i think uh affordability is one thing
availability
is another thing at the minute i think
that as
i mean there's a reason why they're sold
out as well right like people are
excited for them people can see
the their use case for them but
combining that with
the troubles nvidia has had in actually
getting the products
to the people it might be a little
tricky to get
some of these cards but across the next
year easily i think people are going to
be snatching these up as soon as they
become available and and for good reason
like all
the points you made in your review and
today it's it's a very strong case for
that you know
quote unquote entry level card to the
new generation
of graphics and we've we've seen even
more just today like the
radeon announcement was an hour ago so
seeing the 30-70 and
you know the whole 3k series against
radeon's family of cards now as well
all that combined like i don't think
anyone's going to be really left
wanting if they want beautiful graphics
on their desktop right
yeah yeah that's that that is a very
good thing to bring up is availability
uh i've
we mentioned it a little bit uh in the
front end of this conversation but
yeah it's one thing to have a really
good card
like perform like this it's another
thing to actually try and find one
uh whether or not you should be worrying
about them being in stock uh
which is to ask whether or not you need
to be uh upgrading
um i think that's if you're on a gtx
10 series like if you have a gtx 1080
which has been a wonderful card ever
since it came out
but it's time to put it out to pasture
it's starting to show its age
uh been a wonderful card one of the best
like uh high-end cards that we've seen
in a while it's been really able to hold
its own
but now is the time uh if if you are
itching to move
uh to a better card if you're moving on
from 1080p
to 1440p or if your games at 1080p are
starting to lag behind because you're
cranking up a whole bunch of other
settings
the 3070 is that sweet entry point that
you want to move to
if you have if you have an rtx i guess
2070 or better i don't think you need to
worry about these cards
uh unless you're unless you're really
itching for better performance
uh like the 2070 2070 super um
are still really really good cards i
don't think the 3070 is gonna give you
that much of a boost
uh if you jump from those cards but i
also don't i
if you got those cards you got them
pretty recently so i wouldn't even
consider
uh just take that out of your mind don't
even worry about it and anyone who's got
2080ti is probably not watching the
video so we don't need stuff yeah
don't even watch this video if you have
a 2080 ti what are you i'm surprised you
even made it this far in the discussion
uh but yeah 3070 is an alternative to
the 2080 ti
uh for those who don't have that card
now they can access something that is as
powerful as that so
if you're on a gtx 10 series if you're
on gtx 9 series which i know some people
have
uh have been riding out their 90 70s or
970s sorry they're 970s for quite a long
time now
uh this is this is the move that you
want to make sounds like a great card
sounds like there's a lot of people
that are going to want to get it i wish
you all good luck if i get one don't
scalp it don't scalp it don't be that
person
all right no scalpers allowed here at
gamespot.com
you know it is allowed more great pc
gaming content so make sure you
subscribe for that
because across all these new cards
coming out both michael and i
are going to be testing them comparing
them making sure you guys
are all nice and informed to get those
sweet sweet frames and 4k displays
alright good stay tuned and we'll see
you next time
you